authorities in Ukraine say Russia is
targeting several regions including the
capital Kiev in a missile attack let's
go straight to Charles Stratford for
more on that he joins us live from Kiev
so how intense is the strike
it seems to have been one of if not the
largest barrage of cruise missiles uh
since this what seems to be a campaign
by Moscow targeting so far at least
energy infrastructure the presidential
advisor Michael saying at least 120
cruise missiles were launched various
locations across the country including
here in Kiev but also towns like
zaparizia denipro leviv
a Country-Wide barrage I suppose the
attacks started certainly we started to
hear what sounded like missile defense
systems going into action and Loud
explosions around about six o'clock this
morning that was after a uh an alert in
the city
um I'm standing close to the entrance to
the southern Bridge which takes you
across the danipa river and we'd
intended going across that bridge
because that's where we understand some
of the big attacks happened we are
unsure and we cannot confirm how many of
these missiles struck their targets or
were intercepted but as you can see this
road normally would be absolutely packed
with traffic at this time of the day the
police now are stopping people from
moving any further in the last 10
minutes or so we've heard what sound
like active air defense systems still at
work so that would suggest that this
attack is still ongoing there are no
reports of any casualties yet it there
are reports though of residential
buildings having been hit
and the authorities in leviv are saying
that 90 percent of the city is without
electricity the mayor of Kiev mayor
Klitschko has advised key of residents
to charge their phones and devices as
much as they can
in order to obviously be prepared for
expected blackouts and just to put this
in context as I say this campaign or
what seems to be a campaign starting on
October the 10th and more than until
today
more than a thousand missiles and
Kamikaze drones have targeted Ukraine's
energy infrastructure there are already
millions of ukrainians across this city
without reliable power enduring
blackouts without reliable heat as well
during these winter months the president
has already said that it's going to cost
potentially billions of dollars to
repair damage that's already been been
made as a result of these attacks and
that was before today but at this stage
we can't even confirm what was being
targeted but yeah it would not be
surprising at all if indeed this was a
continuation of these attacks targeting
Ukraine's energy infrastructure all
right Charles Stratford there thanks so
much Charles